le lundi j'étais Ilan je vous dis la
vérité j'avais tout j'avais tout ce que
j'y rêvé dans ma vie je venais de me
fiancer avec une fille
on avait enfin pu concrétiser notre
histoire à la télé j'avais décidé de me
ranger à ce moment-là parce que ça y est
j'avais décidé d'arrêter la télé donc
j'avais dit dans mon programme télé ça y
est c'est ma dernière télé c'est terminé
j'avais d'autres projets
je devais signer dans un label de
musique je devais signer une série aussi
un petit connu en France dehors mon
propre TV show à moi j'étais en
discussion avec ça le lundi c'était tous
ces projets là le mardi il y avait plus
rien
et en plus je me faisais insulter par la
France entière ma famille se faisait
insulter par la France entière
menacé de mort menaçantisémite j'ai eu
le droit à tout moi tout tout on va te
crever chez toi sale juif on va venir
violer ta mère on va violer tes petits
frères j'ai eu le droit à tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer et ça fait un an que ça
dure
ça fait un an que ça dure moi en fait je
suis fort